اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه نافذه
التحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف المحلل العسكري
اللواء فايز الدويري لكن نبدا بالخريطه
التفاعليه مع الزميل محمود الكامل ا نعم
زين هناك الكثير من التفاصيل والتي يبدو
انها ستاتي ايضا كذلك تباعا لكن هنا نبدا
من خان يونس حيث المعارك اليوم هنا نشاهد
في هذه الخريطه مختلف مناطق المناورات اي
المختلفه هنا للجيش الاسرائيلي باللون
الاصفر اذا ما توجهنا هنا الى المنطقه
الجنوبيه تحديدا ا الجيش الاسرائيلي يقوم
بعمليه ضغط من ثلاثه جهات من الجهه
الشرقيه
هنا نتحدث من شرق من غرب بني سهيلا اضافه
من الشمال من القراره والعمليات تتركز من
هذه المنطقه كان من من منطقه الصناعه
اضافه هنا باتجاه يبدو ان هذا الضغط يتركز
على الدخول الى مركز البلد وخان يونس هنا
في هذه النقاط طبعا هذه بهذا الاسلوب
يحاول الجيش الاسرائيلي التوغل بشكل حذر
في داخل المناطق السكنيه المكتظه في وسط
خان يونس كما سنشاهد ونشاهد هنا هذه
المناطق ايضا مره اخرى باللون الاصفر
نشاهد بان الجيش الاسرائيلي كان يحاول
ايضا استخدام محور صلاح الدين هذا هو محور
صلاح الدين ودوما ما كانت العمليات تنتقل
من الشرق الى الغرب و بمحاوله السيطره
دوما على السياج الحدودي ايضا هناك المزيد
من التفاصيل التي كانت تاتي تباعا عن
موضوع هنا في الوسط كان هناك هناك
العمليات في
المغازي هناك مصادر دوما تتحدث عن عمليات
تفصيليه او المزيد من التفاصيل في هذه
العمليات نتحدث هنا اذا ما
شاهدنا عم العمليه التي سقط فيها اكثر من
20 قتيلا اسرائيليا يبدو انها كانت مركبه
ومعقده بشكل كبير عاده ما يسبق عمليه
الهجوم البري عمليه التوغل كما كنا نذكر
دوما من الشرق الى الغرب هنا عمليات القصف
بالطيران او المدفعيه عمليات القصف
بالطيران والمدفعيه هي تستخدم بالعاده
ل محاوله تحييد وتحييد القوات الدفاعيه
لكن قوات المقاومه يبدو انها تمكنت من
اي وضع او التمركز هنا بشكل جيد خلال تلك
العمليه وهذا ما يعني بان انها تمكنت من
الكمون خلال مرحله القصف في هذه النقاط
بعد ذلك جاء دور عمليات التمشيط عمليات
التمشيط لقوات الاحتلال ايضا يبدو ان
المقاومه كانت تختبئ بشكل جيد سواء في
الانفاق او الخنادق او الامور الدفاعيه
الاخرى في هذه
المناطق
قوات القوات المتقدمه لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بهذا الاتجاه ايضا يرافقها او
رافقها عمليات قصف اخرى للتمهيد والدخول
لكن قوات المقاومه كذلك كانت ما تزال هي
متمركزه في مكانها بعد هذه العمليه جاءت
عمليه اخرى وهي قوات الهندسه بدات قوات
الهندسه لقوات الاحتلال نتحدث عن عمق
حوالي 600 متر في هذه النقاط
هنا قوات الهندسه للاحتلال قوات الهندسه
بدات بعمليات التلغيم بعمليات لتفجير هذه
المباني وبالتالي تمشيط هذه المنطقه
تمهيدا لتقدم اخر لكن هنا بدا عمليه
التفجير باستخدام قذائف الار بي جي او
التي بي جي في تلك المباني تبع ذلك ايضا
استهداف متزامن ل مدرعه او دبابه ميركافا
كانت تحمي تلك القوات
ثم جاء بعد ذلك عمليه اخرى بعد ثالث لهذه
العمليه وهو حقل الالغام حيث جاءت قوات
قوه الاحتلال بقوات النجده ووجود حقل
الغام هنا كان يتم عمليه التفجير فبالتالي
نتحدث عن سواء يعني مراحل الاشتباك كانت
على ثلاث مراحل لكن سبق ذلك ايضا عمليه
تجاوز للقصف المدفعي القصف بالطيران تمركز
هذا التسلسل من العمليات
الدفاعيه يمكن يعني يظهر امكانيه تحييد
القصف باتخاذ اجراءات دفاعيه مختلفه سنتجه
عبر ذلك وكل هذا سنضعه في تفاصيل التحليل
العسكري لكن اخيرا في ذلك التفصيل ايضا
قوات النجده الاسرائيليه تطلبت بعد ذلك
بعد استهدافها ب كمين من الغام دخول عربات
ثقيله لدعم قوات النجده استمرت 12 ساعه
لانتشال الجثث ومحاولات الانقاذ خلال
الليل لم تكن تلك القوه كافيه المزيد من
التفاصيل في التحليل العسكري معكما زين
العابدين واللواء فايز الدويري شكرا محمود
وسنبدا بهذه العواجل التي اشرت اليها فيما
يتعلق بكيف حدثت عمليه المغازي نشير سيده
اللواء الى ما قاله القيادي في حركه حماس
انه مجاهدون يقول يجاهدون تمركزوا منذ
اسابيع في منطقه العمليه شرق شرق مخيم
المغازي رغم القصف الاسرائيلي الشديد يقول
ايضا انه التعليمات كانت للقوات بعدم
التماع للمجاهدين بعدم التعامل مع القوات
المتغوي في مخيم المغازي في انتظار هدف
ثمين طبعا العمليه وصفت اسرائيليا بانها
معقده ومركبه واشارت القسام الى كيفيه
اجراء العمليه و تنفيذ هذه العمليه وكان
ما غاب عن الروايه الاسرائيليه اكملته
القسام بالحديث عن حقل
الالغام تعليقك اولا على هذه التفاصيل
الجديده يا سيدي اولا يعني تحدثنا بالامس
في لقاءات عده وكانت في بعد تحليلي قبل
صدور هذه المعلومات وقلت ان من خطط ل هذه
العمليه كما عودنا يخطط من خارج الصندوق
دائما تفكيره من خارج التفكير التقليدي
وبالتالي
هناك مؤشرات ا طبعا هذه محاكاه لعمليه
هناك مؤشرات اوليه اولا جيش الاحتلال يقوم
بمحاوله خلق منطقه عازله او بفر زون من ال
المناطق الشرقيه من الحدود الشرقيه
للمناطق المبنيه بدءا من بيت حانون
وانتهاء باطراف
رفح الان نفذ عمليات كثيره معظمها بالقصف
لكن هناك معضله يواجهها وهي عدم وجود
معلومات يقينيه تقود الى الاهداف الحاسمه
الاستراتيجيه المتمثله بالقيادات وب
الرهائن
فهناك
كان عندما يشاهد اي شيء يلفت الانتباه لا
يقوم بقصفه يقوم بتفجيره لماذا لانه في
البدايه قب هو تدخل
القوات والمناطق الصفراء اللي اشرها محمود
هذه ليست ليست اماكن تواجد هذه اخذت عن
مواقع عالميه هي متحيزه حتى للطرف الاخر
ولكن هذه هي المناطق التي تتحرك بها
القوات مناوره ولي تتحرك القوات لا تتواجد
فيها الان هناك بعض المباني تكون ملفته من
حيث الموقع طبيعه المبنى ما شابه ذلك وقد
يوظف هذا المبنى او يستغل مستقبلا يعني
الان هو حسب القياده في القسام يقول انه
المجاهدين رصدوا القوه المعاديه تتقدم وتم
تشخيصها حسب العاجل الذي على الشاشه الان
على انها قوه هندسيه عبر هويتها ومعاد هذا
يفسر انتظار الهدف الثمين هذا ما اقوله
الان هذه المباني هذه
المباني لكل جانب تصور كيف يوظف او يستفيد
من هذا المبنى الجانب الاسرائيلي مقاربته
ان هذا المبنى يوحي له انه سيعثر فيه على
معلومات تفضي الى تحقيق الاهداف تساعد قد
يكون هذا مبنى استخدم في اجتماعات قد يكون
مبنى مسيطر من حيث المراقبه الى غير ذلك
اذا هو لا يقوم
بقصفه يريد ان يصل الى المبنى يتفقد
المبنى يحاول ان يعثر على فتحه نفق يحاول
ان يعثر على ايه
وثيقه الى غير لذلك بعد ان يقوم بتفتيشه
اذا لم يعثر على اي شيء يقوم بتجهيزه
للتدمير ا بالمقابل المدافع كان يقرا كانه
يقرا افكار المهاجم بان هذا الهدف سيكون
مغريا وبالتالي علينا ان نراقب هذا الهدف
الان تقييمات المدافع كانت دقيقه والهدف
كان مغري فتقل الان وصلت قوات
فتشت ولكن لكن كان هناك نوع من الصبر
الاستراتيجي كما اذا جاز التعبير لد المدا
الصبر الاستراتيجي دعنا ننوه ايضا الى ال
يعني مزيد من التفاصيل تتكشف عن عمليه
المغازي حسب المصدر القيادي في القسام
يعني طبعا تم رصد اذا القوه وتم تحديد
هويتها على انها دخلت المبنى وهي قوه
هندسيه واكيد تم معرفه ما لديها من
متفجرات لكن كانت هنالك قوه
راجله داخل حقل الغام معد سابقا بحسب
تصريحات المصدر القيادي اثر المجاهدون حسب
المصدر عدم التعامل مع قوه قوه راجله اخرى
كانت تقف فوق حقل الغام اعدته القسام م
هذا بقى هو الصبر نعم هذا ما اقوله الان
هذا تقييم القسام هذا المبنى مغري سيتم
تفتيشه اذا لم يعثر به على شيء سيتم
تدميره اذا ما هي
الوسائل المتاحه لدي
ل تحقيق هذا الصيد الثمين سادع يفتش سادع
يبدا بعمليه تحضير المبنى للتفجير تحضير
المبنى لل للتفجير يحتاج ساعات ويحتاج قوه
بشريه لانه الان انا كضابط مسؤول هندسي
انا
الان انظر الى المبنى احدد النقاط التي
وضع المتفجرات بها الزم في بعض الحالات ان
احضر اكياس من الرمل عبيها وحطها حتى يكون
التفجير موجه خاصه باتجاه العمود الى يعني
امور فنيه لا تعني المشاهد هذا ياخذ وقت
هذه القوه اثناء عملها تحتاج درجه عاليه
جدا من التركيز اي خطا التفجير سيفشل
وبالتالي يتم تحضيره
بطريقتين بالتمديدات الكهربائيه
والتمديدات التقليديه بالكورت وهذا يتطلب
وقتك نعم واقول لا يجب ان يكون اي هدف اي
هذا اساسيه في علم المتفجرات اي هدف دسم
لا ي يعد للتفجير بطريقتين طريقه كهربائيه
وطريقه عاديه حتى اذا فشلت طريقه تنجح
الاخرى طيب هذا بس جمله واحده لو سمحت لي
زين الان بما انه انا ل تولدت لدي القناعه
وهذه المجموعه لا تستطيع ان تراقب لا
تستطيع ان تحمي نفسها خوفا من ان تخطئ في
عملها اذا سيكون معها قوه حمايه قوه
الحمايه هذه انا الان اخطط لتدمير المبنى
وقوه الحمايه ما هو الخطوه الثالثه لابد
ان تاتي قوه انقاذ ما هي افضل الطرق لقوه
الانقاذ لتتحرك بها يجب ان تاتي من هذا
القاطع ازرع الغام اذا اكتملت خيوط خيوط
اللعبه انجاز التعبير صبر استراتيجي سمح
له بالتحضير الان ماذا جرى ثلاثه امور
وانا لا زال اختلف حتى مع بعض ما ورد من
المعلومات انا اقول تم استهداف الدبابه
اولا لماذا لانها هدف متحرك قد تختفي
والخطوه الثانيه تدمير المبنى وخطوه
الثالثه فتره انتظار حتى تاتي قوه الانقاذ
واقوم بالتفجير وبالتالي لا يمكن ان يكون
الرقم 21 طيب دعنا ننوه الى مجموعه ايضا
من التفاصيل الاخرى التي جاءت في صيغه اخ
عجله نقلا عن هذا المصدر القيادي في
القسام الذي قال يعني بعدما وصلنا الى انه
دخل الفرقه الهندسيه الى المبنى
لتفجيره واعداد المتفجرات ووجود قوه راجله
خارج وكانت هذه القوه في حقل الالغام
واثر المقاتلون عدم التعامل مع حقل
الالغام الذي حدث بعد ذلك وفق هذه الروايه
انتظر المجاهدون انهاء حسب المصدر القيادي
في القسام انهاء القوه عملها
وتثبيت المتفجرات ثم استهدفوه
بقذيفه مضاده للافراد وقال ان
القذيفه كانت
بمثابه المحرض او الشعله او المفجر لمت
تجير المتفجرات المتفجرات التي احدثت
انفجارا دمر المبنى وقضى على افراد القوه
انا متاكد انه العواجل القادمه عن تفجير
حقل الالغام بعد ذلك في القوه المسانده
يعني المفارقه تحدثنا بالامس في المقابلات
بهذا السيناريو بالضبط تعرف لماذا ليس ل
ليس لاني محلل مبدع انا ضابط هندسه ومدير
سلاح الهندسه وهذا تخصصي تخصصي الدقيق
وبالتالي انا تصورت العمليه كما وصفت
بالامس تاتي الاخبار العاجل وتوضح لكن
الروعه في الاداء لا هذا هذا امر خارق
للعاده الصبر الاستراتيجي خارق للعاده
وبالتالي دمر الدبابه دمر المبنى وانتظر
حتى تاتي القوه وتدخل بمجملها في حقل
الالغام لا يعني جمله واحده يقول 21 قتيل
نريد ان نتفق على الترتيب لان انت لديك
ترتيب العواجل تقول ترتيبا اخر حسب
العواجل الترتيب هو تدمير المنزل ثم
الدبابه ثم الدبابه ولم نصل بعد بال في
الى حقل الالغام هل هذا هو ترتيبه لديك تر
انا اشرت بالامس اها هو انا افكر من
المدرسه التقليديه هو يفكر من خارج
الصندوق انا لو كنت اريد ان لو كنت مشرف
على العمليه سادمر الدبابه اولا لان هدف
متحرك قد تختفي وال الهدف الثابت في
اللحظه المناسبه استطيع تدميره بس لو تم
تدمير الدبابه اولا الهدف الثابت سيتحرك
ايضا لانه علم ان المنطقه غير لا يعني
الان ل لن ادخل في جدال تفوق عليك القصان
لن يدخل هو يفكر خارج الصندوق لا لكن انا
اقول مج النظره المهنيه الفاصل الزمني بين
تدمير الدبابه وتدمير المنزل سيكون اقل من
دقيقه اها وبالتالي انا اضمن تدمير
الدبابه ادمر المنزل
وانتظر واذا لدي فنجان قهوه اتناوله حتى
تتكامل القوه داخل حقر الاغام ولكن هو فكر
بطريقه اخرى ونجح شكرا له ا طيب اذا هذا
هو الترتيب الذي ذكره القيادي في المبنى
الدبابه الحقل المبنى
الدبابه حقل الغام وطبعا نحن لسنا في موضع
ان يعني نحكم على كفاءه او عدم كفاءه اي
من هذه
العمليات لكن انت استطيع القول نجحت
بامتياز ا طيب فيما يتعلق ب لماذا انتظر
القسام في رايك هذه المده نحن نتحدث عن
يومين الان حتى ظهرت هذه سي هي هذه
المنطقه دخلوها منذ اسابيع والقصف منذ
اسابيع ليس منذ ايام ولكن قرا افكار العدو
وه يعني سسو يقول اذا تعرف نفسك وتعرف
عدوك نسبه نجاحك
100% اذا تعرف نفس اذا اعرف نفسي ولا اعرف
عدوي لا حظ لي اذا اعرف عدوي ولا احذر
نفسي ولا اعرف نفسي هذه معضله حتى انجح
يجب ان اعرف نفسي وعدوي وهو كان يعرف كيف
يفكر العدو وبالتالي جاءت المقاربه بناء
على توقعات منطقيه منهجيه طيب دع سده
اللواء من المهم هنا ان نعود مره اخرى الى
الخارطه نعود اليك محمود لنعرف وفق هذه
الاخبار العاجله الاماكن التي تم التحرك
فيها وكيف تبدو هذه العمليه على الخارطه
نعم زين عابدين الان نحاول اعاده رسم هذا
السيناريو الذي جاء عبر الاخبار العاجله
منذ قليل وكيف تمت هذه العمليه بتسلسلها
في البدايه المصدر في القسام قال ان
القوات المدافعه كانت تتمركز منذ اسابيع
هنا في الشرق
ال في المنطقه الغربيه مقارنه بالسياج اي
وذلك ظل مستمرا هذا التمركز والرصد ظل
مستمرا حتى رغم القصف الاسرائيلي المكثف
والذي كان يمهد في تلك المنطقه اذا هذه
كانت في المرحله الاولى الان كان هناك
تعليمات لهذه القوات الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه كما نشاهد هنا بلا تقوم باي
عمليه لتكشف مكان هذه القوات خلال تلك
المرحله وذلك بانتظار اهدا اهداف وصفتها
بالثمين الان بعد هذه العمليه وعمليات
القصف بدات القوات بعض القوات تتوغل في
هذا الاتجاه كان هناك حقل الغام موجود
سابقا لكن مع توغل القوات الاسرائيليه
الاولى كانت التعليمات بعدم ال بعدم
الاشتباك مع هذه القوات بانتظار قوات اخرى
اكبر منها اذا عبور ل حق الالغام هذا
القوات تتقدم القوات الاسرائيليه القوات
المدافعه ما تزال في عمليه الرصد ومستمره
في مكانها وقد رافق هذه القوات ايضا
عمليات قصف متقدم هنا نلاحظ بان القوات
المدافعه يبدو انها كانت تتمركز في
مناطق جيده ل للحمايه من القصف المدفعي او
بالقصف بالطيران وهذا تكتيك
ربما يجدر ملاحظته خلال هذه المرحله الان
هناك هنا في مرحله الكمون الاستعداد
للقوات المهاجمه تجاوز مرحله القصف تجاوز
بمرحله التوغل بعد ذلك
ا بدات القوات الهندسيه قوات الهندسه
بالعبور هنا بدا التشخيص بان هذه القوات
يمكن الالتحام معها لكن ليس بعد هنا بدات
القوات بالوصول وصلت الى المباني بعد ان
وصلت هذه القوات الى المباني انتظرت القوه
التي الموجوده في مناطق الدفاع لتلغيم
المبنى كاملا بعد تلغيم المبنى تم استخدام
قذيفه التي بي جي او الار بي جي والتي
عملت وكانها محرض للتفجيرات الموجوده في
تلك المباني الان بعد ذلك قام العمليات
هنا بوجود عمليات الانقاذ حاولت عفوا
استهداف للدبابه بعد ذلك هنا استهداف لهذه
الدبابه التسلسل كان المبنى ثم
الدبابه بعد زرع التحريض ثم جاءت القوه
الراجله للاسعاف وهنا بدا تفجير عمليه
الحقل الالغام ثم جاءت عمليات نجده كان
هذا هو التسلسل على الخريطه زين وهذا
بالفعل ما اكده الان في هذا العاجل على
شاشتنا المصدر القيادي في القسام الذي
نقول عنه تفاصيل هذه العمليه عمليه المغزي
سياده اللواء قال انه بعد ذلك بعد وصول
قوات نجده للمكان ومرورها فوق حقل الالغام
تم تفجيره ثم انسحب المجاهدون بسلام بعد
ذلك قصف العدو وفق القياده في القسام محيط
العمليه وعزلها واستخدم اليات ثقيله بقيت
تعمل بل نحو اثش ساعه لانتشال قتلا يعني
هذا هو يا سيدي العمليه من بدايه لكن دعنا
نشير اولا الى ما نراه على الشاشه الان
وهو اطلاق صواريخ على غلاف غزه يا سيد
فيديو ل سرايا القدس نعم سرايا القدس الان
الاعمال تقييمها يعتمد على النتيجه ما ما
هي
النتيجه الذي خطط والذي نفذ يمنح العلامه
الكامله يمنح العلامه الكامله
المطلقه هذا رقم واحد رقم اين انا اعود
واؤكد انا ابن المدرسه التقليديه افكر
بمنهج معينه والقسام يفكر من خارج الصندوق
ويفاجئ في معظم الحالات انا قلت لك تصورت
هكذا بناء على ثقافتي طيب التي اعتمدها هو
فكر بطريقه اخرى ولكنه حقق العلامه
الكامله تمام ممكن لو اعتمد طريقتي يحصل
على 80% اولا اثر مثل هذه العم عمليه على
الهدف الاسرائيلي باقامه شريط حدودي عازل
شرق غزه من الشمال هذا الهدف هذا الهدف
سيفرض عليه اعاده النظر في اليه التعامل
مع الاهداف سيكون يعني اولا ارتدادات هذه
لها ارتدادات داخليه وخارجيه وهذا حديث
مطول لكن اقول عمليتين يعني انا ساتحدث في
البعد العملياتي اقول هو سيستمر في عمليات
التدمير لكن تكون الاولويه المطلقه ان
يكون التدمير من الجو ما لم يجبر على
عمليات التفخيخ والتفجير ولكن حتى اذا
ا وجد انه من الضروره ان يقوم بعمليه
تفتيش و وتفخيخ هذا المبنى فستكون
اجراءاته الاحترازيه اكثر صرامه وتحتاج
الى اطار زمني مطول وستغطي بكثافه ناريه
هائله تمنع اي حركه ونحن نشاهد بالفعل
الان كثافه ناريه لهذه الصواريخ التي
انطلقت اليوم الى غلاف غزه من داخل قطاع
غزه وفق سرايا وهذا هذا يعني ان المقاومه
لا تزال متماسكه قادره على استخدام
امكاناتها بغض النظر عن هذه الامكانات هي
لا لا تستطيع ان تواجه في حرب مفتوحه قوات
جيش الاحتلال لكنها توظف هذه الامكانات
المحدوده في حرب غير متناظره وبالتالي دخل
في اليوم 110 دخلنا في اليوم 110 لا تزال
الصواريخ تطرق لا تزال عمليه الامس ماثله
امام اعين الجميع وجميع مسؤولي الكيان
تحدثوا بانه يوم مرعب كابوس بحق دوله
الكيان هذا ماذا يعني يعني ان المقاومه لا
تزال متماسكه تدير معركتها بنجاه ولديها
القدره على الاستمرار في المواجهه ايضا من
الاشياء التي تم طبعا اسرائيل دخلت هذه
الحرب بدبابه توصف في العالم بانها من
افضل الدبابات في العالم دبابه الميركافا
لكن واضح انه تم اجراء تعديلات على هذه
الدبابه تتواكب مع ما حدث راينا في الا
اليوم الاول لعمليه طفد الاقصى كيف
استهدفت دبابه المركبه واحرقت في قذيفه
بقذيفه من من طائره من الطائره الان ما
الذي جرى يعني تم تزويدها بمظلات طبعا هي
لديها يعني اشياء كثيره لحمايه مع معطف
الريح لكن هنالك معطف الريح لكن هنالك
الان تغيير في المظل هذا التغيير رقم
اثنين اها يعني كان هناك تغيير قبله وثم
جاء التغيير التغيير السابق اخذ عن من
الاوكرانيين الاوكرانيين اجروا تعديلات و
هذه المظله لمواجهه اي قذائف صغيره الحجم
تاتي من الاعلى طبق على دبابه الميركافا
ثلاث واربعه لكنه لم يفضي الى النتيجه
لماذا لانه ظهر تحدي جديد انا هذه الصور
هذه الصور قبل يومين نشرتها رايترز يا
سيدي ظهر تحدي جديد اختلف عن تحدي الذي
يواجهه الجيش الاوكراني ظهرت لديك قنبله
الشواف والعمل الفدائي هذه المظله التي
عملت اولا وكانت بشكل مختلف وبمواصفات
مختلفه هذه المظله لم تقدم قدمت الاشياء
في اوكرانيا هون لم تقدم لماذا لانه كانت
تلصق بالدبابه العمل الفدائي تلصق
بالدبابه الان هذه المظله اه هذا فيديو لل
للاعلام العسكري في في وبتالي الان لا هذ
عن بدايه الحرب واستهداف المر يا سيدي
الان عليها اضافه عليها اضافه تمنع عمليه
فاعليه المغناطيس بحيث انه يعني
يصعب يصعب الصاق الحشوه بها اها لاحظنا
اكثر من مره انه المقاتل كان
الصق الشواظ على الباب الخلفي للم 113
الصقها على جانب الدبابه وضع عبوه العمل
الفدائي توضع وضع وليس الصاق وضعها
وشاهدناها اكثر من مره هذا العمل هذا
العمل المظله القديمه لا تؤمنه هذهه
المظله الجديده يبدو انها تتعامل
مع الجاذبيه المغناطيسيه تحيد هذه الاشياء
وتمنع من
التصاقها يلصق العبوه بال هذا ما تحدث عنه
طيب هذه المظله يعني ما الذي ستفعله
للدبابه اذا كانت الدبابه تلصق بها العبوه
من اماكن اخرى ثم هل م الغاء مغناطيسيه
الدبابه مشكله كبيره بالنسبه للمقاومه لا
سيكون هناك كل معذره لها حل ايو يعني
لا كان هناك ما هو
اعقد هناك يعني الذي
تغلب على التعامل مع الروبوت الذي يصدر
الاصوات حركه الدبابه واطلاق النيران
والذي تعامل مع الروبوت
المقاتل الروبوت لانه نوعين من الروبوت
استخدمتهم اسرائيل واستطاعت القسام ان تجد
الحلول للتعامل معها من استطاع ان يحيد
روبوت تايجر المقاتل سيحي هذ هذه هذه
المظله هذا ما اتوق شكرا جزيلا اللواء
فايز دويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
شكرا لك شكرا